I I went through a few places in London
where it could have been Baghdad if it
wasn't for the
uniquely um English buildings it could
have been Bagdad there it did not look
at all like um like London and that's
you know that's I guess racist to say in
today's world but it's not because
there's no assimilation no assimilation
when that's not happening how long is
London or the West going to
survive come on Glenn stop being racist
diversity is our strength manate how
divide and conquer I mean
how that's what everyone says I'm just
telling you what the party line is the
party line is diversity is our strength
uh and diversity can be our strength if
everybody who comes from different
places comes together and says we are
all American or we are all British yes
we all we all subscribe to the same
ideas corre we all believe in in the
future of our country we want to live by
a broadly similar set of rules we all
believe that men and women are equal for
example etc etc etc um but what we have
is something else we don't have that
which is what I think a healthy
multiethnic society looks like uh we
have multiculturalism and that's the
idea that people should be free to live
any which way they want speak any
language they want integrate or not
integrate up to them really uh and uh
you know operate completely in complete
isolation from the country to which they
come and when there's enough of them to
demand that that country becomes more
like the country from which they
came we have a our country's motto is
urbus Unum from many one we're not one
anymore there's nothing that none of the
big principles bring us together and
when I hear people on the street quoting
Hitler
I and and I'm so used now to be calling
be called a Nazi because and I don't
know how I've won the defender of Israel
award I I don't know how I'm uh
anti-semite but somehow or another I'm
an anti-semitic Nazi and then I hear
people on the
streets quoting
Hitler I
wonder is anyone going to wake up from
this are there no no no no no these
people who spent seven years at least
calling everybody a Nazi they don't
recognize Nazis when they see them and
it's interesting because the counter
protesters we talked about a second ago
they were described as the far right in
in all the media Publications in this
country uh they were held up as the real
problem and I keep saying to people when
I think of what we in the UK call the
far right I know it's a little bit
different over in the US but in the UK
when we talk about the far right what we
mean is people who are racist
people who are homophobic people who
think that women are second class
citizens and should be treated as such
and people who believe in the use of
violence to achieve their political
objectives we've had the far right on
the streets of our city for five weeks
and it doesn't look like these counter
protesters it looks like people shouting
for Jihad rise up rise up Army of
Muhammad and as you say praising Hitler
but if you import lots of people from
places where praising Hitler is normal
this is what happens so where do we go
from here how do how do we I mean your
your government and our government is
just getting weaker and weaker it's it's
honestly if you had to judge them by
their actions they're all in with BLM
protest burning cities they're all in
with
Hamas just judging by their
actions so I think it's much worse than
that I don't think they're all in I
think they don't know what to do they're
scared they're terrified we have a
political system that filters out
certainly in this country anyone who's
prepared to speak the truth I mean we
just talked about one example of it the
one politician in the conservative party
who was willing to be honest is the one
that they've got rid of uh and uh we
have a political system that is
calibrated precisely around um making
sure that nobody who's actually honest
ever reaches a position of power and if
by some miracle they do we get rid of
them um and I don't know how that
changes when I speak to my Jewish
friends in the UK I'll be honest with
most most of them are talking about
leaving to go where Israel I probably
not Israel maybe the they they hope that
that America is a place that still holds
on to its values I I hope so too but I
I'm shocked but why but on what I'm
seeing all across America I
mean shocked i' been I've been warning
about it this is why the ADL uh has
called me uh you know a Nazi and
anti-semite because I've been warning
about the seeds of the Holocaust they're
they've been planted here for 15 20
years and nobody's nobody's looking at
what's sprouting up everywhere and uh
and I guess it's you you're a Nazi if
you say hey we should pull those weeds
from the garden and make sure that they
don't grow and now here they are and
it's worse than I
thought well what you have is a
combination of two things both very d
dous one is obviously Western countries
now have significant populations of
people who uh and I'm not talking about
peaceful modal Muslims here I'm talking
about islamists we we have we have a
population uh big enough of islamists
now and uh they are they seem to get
along very well inexplicably so uh with
all of these uh woke idiots that have
been created on college campuses and in
schools and this is where the beautiful
I mean this is a magical phenomenon of
quiz for Palestine comes from
it's people who who don't understand
anything about the place about which
they're talking about and Glenn I I I am
actually starting a movement I'd like
people like us to get together and start
fundraising for one-way tickets to Gaza
for all of these people so they can
experience the true benefits of
everything that they're praising um
hopefully that that may be a way to
solve the problem I I don't this
what is it stupidity is it just that is
it just stupidity it is yes it's
stupidity and ideology and this is the
point that I think uh people in the west
and I'm someone who was born in the
Soviet Union so I have a slightly
Outsiders perspective we are victims of
our own success here in the west yes
we've built some of the most incredible
Societies in the history of humanity
including by the way on those very
Progressive values that these people
love to talk about when if you you know
if if you care about women's rights
where is a better place to be a woman
than the United States of America if you
care about gay rights where is a better
place to be gay than the United States
of America if you care about all sorts
of other issues where is a better place
to be than the United States of America
and other Western countries nowhere but
because we have given our citizens all
these incredible opportunities where
they don't have to think about anything
other than you know wake up go to work
make money have time with my family Etc
they're incredibly susceptible to
ideology and the one thing we've
forgotten in the West which strikes me
as odd given that you only have to look
back about 80 years to see how powerful
ideology really is yeah um we've
forgotten that if you brainwash people
long and hard enough and if you uh if
you don't teach them the values of your
own society and instead teach them to
hate the values of your own Society you
will very quickly end up in a place
where these people hate your own society
and as long as American schools and
American colleges continue to teach
young Americans that America is evil
then you will see the scenes that you
see on the streets of America where you
have all these young people tearing down
American flags uh from uh you know
various posts and and whatever uh
because this is what they believe and
and why would we be surprised about that
when they have spent their entire life
being educated by people who hate your
country and its values so how do you how
do you turn somebody around you meet
somebody and they're they're honest but
they're stupid or they're IND but they
believe it but they'll have a
conversation with you what do you say to
them travel travel
buy a ticket fly somewhere else go to
another part of the world see how the
rest of the world lives see how the rest
of the world lives I bet you people who
go over to other countries go to
somewhere in Central Asia where I grew
up in usbekistan see how people live in
usbekistan and then tell me America is
bad tell me America is bad after you've
been there go go somewhere else go to
Thailand go to Cambodia go to go to some
part of the world where people are not
quite as rich or as free as
you tear down their flag go to to
Cambodia and tear down the Cambodian
national flag in front in front of the
Parliament building there or in front of
one of the buildings there try it try
see what happens go to North Korea it's
it's the this it's the Socialist Utopia
that you keep telling me about you know
I only grew up in the Soviet Union you
must know better go there go to North
Korea have a look see what happens there
you know you can't speak freely in
America okay try that let's find out
travel that's one thing that you know
seeing is believing this is why
people are so I don't know if you saw I
wrote an article for the Free Press
about called the day the delusions died
about October 7th Massacre um seeing is
believing this is why people are so
shocked and by the events of recent days
and weeks it changed you too though
didn't it yeah yeah yeah I'll be honest
with you Glenn and this is probably the
first time that I've said this so people
who watch a lot of my stuff will will
will be surprised but I've spent the
last six years since we started
trigonometry my YouTube show and since
I've become a a public commentator
really saying I'm very concerned about
the things that are happening on the
left but I come from the left I'm
somewhere in the center there are a lot
of things that trouble me on the right
and and all of those things are still
true right but as of as of five weeks
ago my my view is um this isn't the time
for for ambivalence uh there is a side
that wants me killed and there's a side
that doesn't I'm going to go with the
one that doesn't